but a lot of these people know that the
average person
views what they're doing is wrong so
they have to lie about it
that's why i mentioned this meme where
you know dr king is saying
judge people based on the content of
their character because most people
agree with that
in order to instill racist nazi-like
ideology
they have to use clever semantic games
like anti-racist
are you anti-racist it's not enough to
not be racist you must be anti-racist
and then you ask them what anti-racism
means and you know what ebermex candy
says
it means you must discriminate against
people on the basis of race i'm pretty
sure dr king said not to do that
oh but they don't care they don't
actually believe him this is the one
thing that really gets these people
whenever i'm talking to a woke person
i'll ask them the first thing i will ask
him is do you believe in dr king's dream
i've actually now started hearing him
say no it's in it's in my other book the
myth of white fragility taking down
robin d'angelo's disgraceful book
she says in there that dr king's dream
of color blindness is a problem so does
candy
you know they say that you can't have a
colorblind society because
there is so much systemic racism and
institutional injustice
that you have to actively be an
anti-racist and be racist
so it's essentially building a new jim
crow all right they want a new jim crow
and it's not about voting laws it's
about who gets to be
the upper side now so they want to flip
things because white people were bad
before
we need to now elevate black people and
people of color and go ahead and make
that the actual
legitimate power balance i don't think
they actually care about white people
i think they just want power and they
found a path to get it and it doesn't
matter which race they trample on
that's why they ragged on asians for so
long interesting well
we're a good target you know because we
were oppressors you know they've got
that they can't take that away
there was oppression there was slavery
there was women couldn't vote all those
things are true
bald white guys and bad wigs wrote a
bunch of crazy stuff
right but we also fixed it right and we
gave those powers up
you look at how they actually claimed
asians were more privileged for a long
time
and that's why i think the issue where
they go after whiteness
is that it's an easy way to go to
someone and say all of your problems
come from someone else right it's
demagoguery
they accused trump of doing the exact
same thing when trump did to a certain
degree but not nearly as much as they do
when they say whiteness over and over
again and privilege and all that stuff
they're basically just telling people
the reason you failed is not your fault
it's that guy over there it's it's
brilliant i saw this great meme from a
leftist on facebook
it was it said it's one of those twitter
memes where it says
employees colon we need better wages and
and healthcare healthcare because we're
suffering and dying
and then it says capital colon no and
then it says woke capital no hashtag blm
rainbow flag heart
and i i gotta i gotta say i love that
meme well i certainly don't agree with
their view on capitalism
at least they're starting to notice the
corporatist establishment is not
going to give the leftists what they
want they're just going to put a rainbow
flag up and say now you can't be mad at
us
well and what i love most though is they
they needed an enemy
all right and like you said okay it's
not so much maybe they don't actually
believe the white people the problem i
think they do
but they made whiteness evil they turned
they turned it into an ideology that
doesn't exist whiteness didn't exist for
me
i've been white for a long time all
right i didn't have a methodology
towards my whiteness
i didn't wake up and say okay 9 to 9 30
i'm going to press black people
you know 9 45 i'll switch to trans
people no
i was busy living my life but they
othered us
they used their own methodology and now
they've got someone to go against
and they've got something to they've got
spoils because what they did is they
take their identity groups
right and they create a grievance and
they take that grievance to someone who
has something they want
and they use their power they aggregate
power by delivering the spoils to their
identity group the problem is they've
run into the circular firing squad
problem
they can't rectify among their identity
groups the problems they have because
you've got black people beating up
asians
you know you've got a lot of issues and
jews and you've got problems between
these groups
that are are not just cognitive
dissonance they're ideological
dissonance
and they can't rectify that you remember
what happened in the uk when the muslims
were protesting the
lgbt curriculums in schools right it was
really weird because
you'd have these woke people come out
and start arguing with muslims and you'd
have like women in like full niqab
and then you'd have a man screaming in
the face of a woke person who's confused
and there was one video where the guy's
like i'm here to help you i'm on your
side i'm here to help you i'm like no
you're not
the the muslim guy's like this is
degeneracy and you're wrong
and i'm like i wonder if these people
who truly believe their insane
psychobabble have ever actually spoken
with a religious conservative person
and i don't mean a christian i mean when
they come out they they
you know i had a friend who has that a
picture of a woman in a hijab and it
says something like hope or something
like you know hope underneath it
and i'm like it's really fascinating
that you are propping up religious
conservatism
and like because islam is substantially
more traditional than even modern
christianity
totalitarian if it's implemented the way
you know the
the salafists and that's the fun part
there's this perfect circular firing
squad right there is you've got people
who hate gays and want to hang them from
cranes
arguing with a gay dude who's telling
them that they're oppressed
and arguing about a curriculum that they
don't want in their school
there's no way you could square that
circle and that's that's how we beat
them though
but that's how we beat them the issue is
i don't think i think the circular
firing squad matters to a certain degree
you right now we've got this like school
board member in in california
they're demanding she resigned because
she said a bunch of disparaging things
about asian people
but at the time they were allowed to do
that it was part of their ideology to
disparage asians
now that they can't do that they're
coming for you know circular filing
squad firing squad but this person said
i'm not going i don't care
and how long until they just move on to
the next stupid nonsense and start
claiming that
you know who knows what the next thing
is going to be just some some ridiculous
form of oppression that a minority group
will have
it's like oh you know people with with
long fingernails that you know they just
grow too long so
you know they're oppressed people who
eat too much they're oppressed we know
that
here's where i think it might bite them
is they they invented this several
generations of entitled
grievance mongers i call them right who
have been told that they're
it's not your fault it's those people's
fault now they work at places like
google you're familiar with timnit
gaburu
she was the head of google's artificial
intelligence ethics
team oh yeah she's a black woman she
built a team
of the purple haired freakazoid robots
and all her best friends right
they wanted to publish a paper the
problem was it went through google's
review board and they said first of all
the science is kind of garbage
second of all you're trashing our
company and third of all this is
basically just
woke grievances right fix it
or we're not going to let you put it out
under our name and they launched it and
then google
fired her yeah right and all of a sudden
it's not because she violated both
scientific principles academic
principles and
company policy it's because she's black
and now she's got
thousands of google employees who are
backing her play
because she's been told you're not wrong
you're just being oppressed right if
you're black at google
then and you don't get everything you
want you have a right to demand
that they they meet your grievances
james damore
was an excellent example of how insane
the ideology is
so uh you're familiar with james the
more imagine ian are you yeah so for
those that aren't familiar he wrote a
letter about ways to improve the
workplace between men and women
and it was based on scientific research
and he was like sharing with people and
then a bunch of feminists got really
offended by it
and then he ended up losing his job
there was a lawsuit i think they settled
the funny thing is james damore's
document was actually
based upon modern feminist theory it
said things like
workplaces were designed by men for men
and that we need to change things to
better suit women
according to a study women prefer social
social experiments
experiences more so than like top-down
and isolated
work environments if men prefer x and
women prefer y
the workplace must be some combination
of the two to accommodate for women
the women said how dare you imply women
are inherently one way or another
we are angry you should be fired to
reiterate how insane that is
he was literally saying that google's
work environment was built by patriarchy
and that he they needed to accommodate
the fema the the woman
better and so they got mad and demanded
he lose his job the women did
isn't that amazing he's he's basically
agreeing with everything they've been
saying
you can't accommodate them that's the
thing you can't accommodate them and
what they figured out is all they need
is a disparity of outcome
all right you say we have a disparity
there are too few black
engineers you know with freckles working
at google
therefore they're that's a racist
systemic
issue that they have to deal with and
then they jump right from there instead
of looking at outcomes and say well
maybe there aren't a lot of black
freckled people
who get into the tech field maybe that's
why there aren't as many at google
they're like no no no it's racism right
so they skip the step
of the scientific process it says you
identify a disparate outcome
and then you look at potential causes
identify the
ones that correlate the best they jump
straight from that to systemic racism
but the problem is that eliminates any
look at root causes and you can never
fix it
so that's where equity comes in so one
really great example of the corruption
colleges
not majority female okay many many
colleges i should say are majority
female so okay so
so men are now the minority in colleges
do we now start abolishing all of the
women's programs women's scholarships
no and creating men's ones i don't think
so so you think the majority should get
privileged money and access and
resources what are you a bigot
shouldn't the minorities be the one who
get help because they're in the minority
well that would be like dudes in college
at this point because it's mostly women
and here's the thing that changed in my
lifetime when i was in elementary school
that was when they started that stuff
and they said there aren't enough women
going to college there aren't enough so
they literally
inside of several decades managed to
flip that on its head
now the question is what do we want do
we want equality of outcome
right we want to make sure that every
group in society is equally represented
in every outcome
that we can come up with because that's
what wokeness demands and it can't be
met
because humans humans don't work that
way so what we have to figure out is how
do we get back to equality of
opportunity
because that's all you can do and that's
that's where i think our side needs to
look at it and say
we can see the disparate outcome i agree
with you there's too many black people
in prison i don't want them in prison
except most of them committed crimes so
how do we stop
they're committing crimes not how do we
get them out of prison well there's
there's interesting arguments about that
uh questions about whether or not based
on race they'll get harsher sentences
for the same
crime which there are stats that show
and so the issue i see
there's real instances of racism there's
real instances of bias
uh historical racism has created a
ripple effect throughout history
in today's modern generation and an
honest person like i think you'd hear
this from tucker carlson
of course there's racism we'd like to
solve these problems
but these people are hustlers they're
grifters they're manipulators
they they tell the privileged elites
they're oppressed they would claim to
you
that oprah winfrey or serena williams
are oppressed meanwhile a homeless
veteran sleeping under a gutter who
happens to be white is the oppressor
that's the insanity of their ideology
honest people say
yeah you know racism is a problem i
think we've actually done a lot in this
country to do away with
it we've passed many new laws there's
been new supreme court rulings we've
done a tremendous job
ending these things but there are
remnants of these historical policies
and actions
in private and public affairs redlining
and blockbusting
very serious consequences for for uh for
various people
well the the the people on the left
manipulate
the goodwill of regular people who don't
want racism
and they lie to them and tell them they
can't advance exactly we've done a lot
of legal good
uh to combat racism in the united states
emotional
is like an up and down back and forth
situation and when we let the media
tell us that we're different because of
the colors of our skins
that kind of is damaging or undoing a
lot of the good we can do to unify
humans in our culture but i do agree
that legally the united states has done
a lot of
positive things to bypass and break
through the racist curtain
and wokeness is re-segregating that's
the problem
identity politics is re-segregation and
they're they're breaking people out and
saying no your skin color actually is
more important
than the content of your character and
so we're gonna put you in this block
and you will vote with these people and
you will identify with these people
and you will get spoils from us because
you're one of these people
and that's the most destructive thing to
what is a
a republic of equals i can even imagine
is to say that no the intangible
characteristics
matter more than your character that
that offends me more than anything else
they do
and i think we can call out races we can
call out these problems
and say we want to fix them and we want
to help but we have to do it by saying
yes the content of your character
matters more in the color of your skin
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you